welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and after over 500 days of no new marvel
content
the mcu is back with one division the
disney plus series has a lot to unpack
from it and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down
episodes one and two pointing out all
the easter eggs
giving our theories and explaining the
ending up top we're going to be dropping
some big fan theories
and then we'll continue with our more
traditional breakdown but it's all going
to be time coded in the description
below if you want to skip ahead
don't know yet now the last time we saw
vision he was giving a piece of his mind
to thanos
and wanda was moping around after the
avengers saved the universe
cheer up love it's a funeral the series
itself picks up with us having very
little idea over what it is exactly
that's going on
and why the characters are in this
strange 1950s sitcom
now in death vision actually turned gray
and this was similar to his silver
costume in the comics that became a big
part of the character
though we know from the trailers that
that won't remain i love the black and
white aesthetic here that sort of ties
into that easter egg
and who knows he may turn back to being
grey at some point
as for wonder she's clearly created this
pocket dimension
and though we don't know exactly what's
going on just yet there was a big clue
in one of the tv spots that was recently
released
now i just want to give a huge shout
outs to aqui stats on twitter for
sending me this through
and the trailer ends like most do with a
voice over announcing when it's coming
out
however instead of saying streaming
friday it sounds like he says dreaming
friday
and when you turn on the closed captions
you can see that that is indeed the case
an original series streaming friday
exclusively on disney plus
swan division an original series
streaming friday exclusively on disney
plus
the mistake seems deliberate and to me
it's hinting that wonder is actually
dreaming this entire reality
and due to her powers it may have
manifested this could mean that the
character is actually asleep at the
center of it all
and the reality is building up around
her the characters that we see
throughout the episodes could have been
sucked into this
and this is why they're unable to
remember exactly what's going on outside
the people that the pair interact with
could have been doctors or psychologists
on the outside
trying to help her with their grief and
they've become trapped in this dimension
and are unable to escape from it visions
tie could also be hinting at people
being enclosed in something
and from what we see on it it has a
rectangle with two dots inside of it
these two dots could represent both
wonder and vision who are stuck inside
this box that the former has dreamt up
anyway this streaming instead of
streaming is a small thing
so i may have nothing going on but i
definitely thought that i'd drop it in
before we got deeper into the episode
there are rumors that nightmare is
actually going to be a big villain in
doctor strange 2
and that this show will tie directly
into that so dreams and nightmares in
general could reflect the way that
things are going forward
now that brings us to another big
character who could in fact have helped
wonder create this reality
catherine harness playing a nosy
neighbor and we now know
that her name is definitely agnes
throughout the trailers we've seen that
she actually appears as a witch at one
point
and to me this solidifies the theory
that she is agatha hawkness
if you take the first syllable of her
name i.e ag
and then add the last syllable of her
surname i.e ness and push them together
you get agnes so to me yeah it
definitely lines up now
now recently she was shown in the
posters wearing a stone around her neck
which is also a common motif of agatha
harkness
so it's all starting to fall into place
isn't it she just seems to be having a
blast
and in case you don't know agatha
herself is a witch that's over thousands
of years old
in the comics she's been both an ally in
villain to wonder but she could have
helped her to create the reality
and have ulterior motives behind it hell
she may even be working for nightmare
herself
and perhaps what they're doing will be
similar to how loki was the big bad of
the avengers
but thanos was actually the one behind
the scenes who was controlling it all
so lots and lots of theories there and
if you're enjoying these points so far
then i'd love it if you click the thumbs
up button
i think i'm one of the only big channels
that didn't get early access to one
division which
i found a bit weird so even if you just
do that little thing
it massively supports me there was a bit
of drama behind the scenes that i might
talk about in an upcoming video
but you'll have to subscribe to stick
around and hear what that is hey lord
you're in right there now as for the
episodes themselves
they actually call back to several old
sitcoms from the 50s and 60s
the dick van dyke show never bathed on a
saturday features a dress that wonder
wears at one point
and there's also an episode of bewitch
that has a variety act
which is similar to what wonder and
vision dress up as sorry nice that
they're paying homage to what's come
before
we join them as they drive towards west
view having just been married
in infinity war the pair's dream was
always to run away together
so it makes sense that they'd escape to
the fictional location of west view
now in story writing when things go west
it means that they've either fallen
apart
or have changed from what they
originally were this term originates
from the first world war
and thus it carries some significance
here a west
view of the world would mean that things
have changed drastically
which is likely why the dimension is the
way that it is
could be reaching there now i don't know
what tv shows wonder got growing up
but clearly they influenced her into
creating this idyllic world
vision is a character that could not be
brought back because of the snap
and thus wanda has likely held a grudge
against reality
so this is why she has created her own
now on top of the tv shows
this setting is also inspired by the
graphic novel vision from tom king
in that the character lived out the
ideal life with a manufactured family
but things slowly started to fall apart
in the background we can hear a jolly
old theme tune
and vision heights face from the mailman
purely because he's not in his human
form
they enter the house which is numbered
to 800 and this could be a reference to
earth 2 800 from the marvel comics
though that's that's probably also a
reach now though they are married at
this point
we discover later on that they don't
have rings which shows the
contradictions in the world
and where things don't line up in a
complete opposite of the mcu we see
vision with a newspaper
and when you look at the headline it
states little baby jane's first words
tickle her mother
on earth 616 people have been dead for
five years and then were mysteriously
brought back so
this taking up the front page shows how
disconnected everything is
it also shows how pristine and perfect
that this world is
even though everyone should be very
miserable yay depression
now vision's dress code in general is
very similar to the husband from
bewitched
and it's nice that they've paid this
close attention to detail even down to
the costume design
we discover on the calendar that their
anniversary is on the 23rd
and this number 23 could also be a
reference to the 23 mcu films that have
come before this series
on top of the number is a heart and this
ties in divisions boss coming over for
dinner
who just so happens to be called mr hot
now the name mr hart
could be a reference to agent heart or
jonathan hart from the comics
both are quite high powered beings and
though i don't think this guy will go
forward to be a super powered hero
it could be setting things up now agnes
comes over and discusses her anniversary
being on june 2nd
and this is actually the day that the
marvel digital store closed
and it just so happens to be my dad's
birthday as well so
you know it's it's all connected now we
see that vision's work that he can move
at super speed
and at the end of the second episode
discover that wonder is pregnant
from the trailers we know that the pair
are having twins and these will likely
be wicking in speed
the super speed that vision displays
here will clearly be inherited
and thus it's laying the groundwork for
a lot of things to come
throughout both entries are these
commercials that kind of play on
advertisements at the time
but they also have some subtext which
which does kind of hint out what's going
on
in the first one we see a stock
industries toaster which carries
a lot with it from wander's backstory we
know that a stock missile landed in
front of her when she was a child
and because it didn't explode her and
her brother were forced to look at it
for days
stark holds a lot of things over her
young life as does strzoker
whose watch appears as a commercial in
the second entry
that has a hydra logo on it and he was
being revealed as one of their agents
who had been experimenting on both
wonder and pietro
therefore we can gather that these
products are somewhat influenced by her
subconscious
and it does further confirm that she is
the one controlling the reality
now the toaster starts to flash red and
i believe that this is the outside world
namely the agents of sword trying to
infiltrate the dimension
they would likely be using stock tech in
order to do this
as the industry is laced throughout the
majority of 616 society
in case you don't know who the agents of
sword are they basically deal with space
and interdimensional issues
whereas the agents of shield deal with
problems on earth they go beyond that
but they're likely doing this on our
planet because
marvel studios just hate the agents of
shield for for some reason
bring back daisy now mr and mrs hart
arrive at the visions
and the latter is played by deborah joe
rupp who you may know from the sitcom
that 70s show
which the series will likely be riffing
on agnes comes over and helps wander to
prepare
food and when the table is getting made
we can see a wine bottle with the letter
m on the neck
on the label itself is maison du maypri
and this translates to house of contempt
the use of m here and house of course
ties into house of m
which is a story that relates heavily to
this series
at the end of the run wanda actually
wiped out the majority of mutants on
earth
however here it could be possible that
she births them into existence
which could mean that the x-men can
feature in the show going forward
or just the the marvel universe in
general now the group will sit around
and have dinner
and the boss starts to go wild when
trying to find out what their history is
again this could tie into him being a
doctor or psychologist
and he is remembering his life outside
the dimension in which he was trying to
find out what was going on
the last time my boss spoke to me i quit
my job to do youtube full-time
and i tell you what i would have made
him choke as well one day
clearly isn't too happy about them
asking deep questions either
and the last she starts to go wild now
it is rumored that in doctor strange too
that the madness in the title
in the multiverse of madness will indeed
be her mrs harp pretty much breaks
through the illusion in order to tell
her to stop making him choke
and it's clear that she wants to remain
in this reality and will cause
issues for those that try and take her
out of this the pair leave
seemingly even unable to remember the
events that have just transpired
showing that wonder can also alter the
consciousness of those trapped in this
space
the end of the episode has his cut to
the agents of sword watching things play
out on screen
and in episode 2 they send in what looks
like a drone
before a beekeeper climbs out of a sewer
at the end
on his back is the logo of the agency so
we do know that they are indeed one in
the same now
jump over to episode 2 and this time we
see an animated intro for the series
this is extremely similar the one used
for i dream of genie
which this episode is clearly riffing
upon now we watch wonder envision
preparing for a magic show that they
perform later on in the episode
on the cabinet that the pair use we can
see the mind stone which is of course
a big part of vision's character the
extent of what's going on
also stretches beyond that as we
discover the axe name is glamour and
illusion
everything going on in the show is of
course an illusion and this could hint
that wonder is even subconsciously aware
of what's going on
now the people in and around her could
either be trapped or
be part of the illusion there are rumors
that both the grim reaper and mephisto
will be appearing in the show
and if i had to put money on who they
are i would probably guess the mailman
dennis
and maybe dottie there are a range of
possibilities over who they could all be
but for the meantime yeah that that's
that's my guess
i swear i don't know for definite now
dennis of course travels to town
looking in on people through the guise
of being a mailman
and dottie pretty much controls all the
ins and outs of the city
from agnes we learn that she's
infiltrated all parts of society
and is the key to everything making me
believe that
she is a higher power however she does
bleed
showing that she's not actually in
control of the reality
so maybe her being being that is just
simply a misdirect
now at the meeting we're also introduced
to monica rambo who he last saw as a kid
in captain marvel
from the behind the scenes images we
know that she's actually an agent of
sword
and if you know her from the comics then
you'll be well aware that there's a lot
in store for her
in the source material rambo is actually
a hero known as photon
and thus it is possible that she ends up
gaining these abilities by being in this
reality
now vision ends up eating chewing gum
and this gets clogged in his gears
and makes him seem drunk honestly this
performance really didn't gel with me
that much
and i have to say that on the whole i'm
still a bit unsure of the whole concept
i'm not sure if this is gonna work for
nine episodes and to me it feels like a
bit of a weird art project that's going
on far too long
it's really hard to kind of vibe with it
right now because we don't really know
what's happening behind the scenes
and i wish that we had at least some
setup to give context to the event
because i feel like a lot of people will
become lost due to the strangeness of it
however these are only the first two
episodes so it may grow on me as things
progress
marvel are often accused of not taking
chances and they do hear but
i just feel like the whole concept is a
bit too short to sustain interest
without knowing more about what's going
on in the background
anyway the pair do a magic show in which
vision actually carries out miracles
and wonder must cover for him so that
they don't stand out
i guess they never saw the prestige
because a magic show is actually the
only place you can get away with stuff
like this
but they cover it up to the point that
even the dude who looks like david
schwimmer
doesn't realize what's going on i think
i feel kind of bad calling him david
schumer i may get to all the time
and if you're watching this mate uh i'm
sorry for for doing such a played out
joke that's
that's probably ruined your life my bad
now after the gum is pulled out from
vision
they're awarded the prize from dutty and
it looks like things are gonna be just
swell
the pair return to their house and wanda
wishes herself into pregnancy after
saying that the children will need
popcorn
the pair are interrupted by a noise from
outside and this is where they encounter
the beekeeper
now there are a lot of theories that
this is mephisto but as we've said yeah
he's got a sword logo on the back so
he's not mate you can
shut the hell up they'll be swarming
around him all creepy as hell though but
i just feel like this is part of the
costume and nothing more
of course let me know if i'm wrong
though now wonder then rewinds time
and completely changes the reality to be
a 70s show
a 70s show is that even a pun we don't
know but we know that going forward
the era in which episode 3 takes place
will be that one
and it'll finally add a bit of color to
the proceedings now as mentioned earlier
the twins will be born
and these will be the mutants wiccan and
speed
this opens the door not only to the
mutants in the mcu
but it of course sets up the x-men who
likely appear in phase 5
i'm guessing now we end with the radio
broadcast saying who's doing this to you
wonder
which does confirm that there is an
outside force but due to the dreaming
comment
i think that they may have just enabled
wanda to bring on herself
rather than forcing her through it as a
whole i did feel like this was a bit all
over the place
and even judging some of them the early
social media reactions
it just seems very divisive marvel have
made 23 great films though so i'll give
them the benefit of the doubt
for now but we'll see what happens in
the next one
anyway that wraps up the first two
episodes and i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts on it
i've seen a lot of people say that they
loved it a lot of people confused
and some are just saying that this is
the worst mcu thing that they've ever
seen
what matters though is what you think
and as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
draw in which we're giving away three
copies of the hobbit and lord of the
rings 4k box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on you
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episodes you want to
follow us on twitter
instagram or come chat to us on discord
and that's going to be linked in the
description below
and we'd love to have you as part of the
family if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the theories on the season
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over the best of them so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
anyway if not thanks for watching until
the end of the video i've been paul
you been the best i'll see you next time
take care
peace